on August 5th 1857 a 4,300 kilometer
long cable was laid across the Atlantic
Ocean it provided a link between Britain
and the Americas further strengthening
their social and economic alliances now
information could be represented as a
pattern of electrical pulses and sent
across the world almost instantaneously
stock tickers and money transfers these
were commercial applications invented by
Western Union which ushered in a new era
of global communication stand by for
this announcement Germany has invaded
Poland and has bombed many tons
general mobilization has been ordered
input
at frogs
and consequently this country is at war
with Germany the world which is the real
cause of the war that today threatens
the freedom of mankind Aegis Parkinson
yatha I
[Applause]
mayor japanese of the text Pearl Harbor
Hawaii by air President Roosevelt has
just announced
during World War two
Germany Italy and Japan were far
outnumbered by the Allies their only
conceivable path to victory was the
ability to launch widespread surprise
attacks so the goal of encryption
technology was to automate the one-time
pad using an encryption machine ideally
this machine would accept an input
letter apply a random shift and output
the encrypted letter however all
machines follow the same principle they
begin in some initial configuration
known as a state they accept some input
they do an operation with the input and
then they produce an output the
operation from initial state to final
state is always predictable and
repeatable so the goal is to produce
identical machines that output a
scrambled sequence of ships which took a
long time to repeat
[Music]
therefore Alice and Bob could generate
an identical shift sequence as follows
first they need to share identical
machines and agree on an initial
position which is defined as the key
setting then they align their machines
to the same position and finally cycle
through the identical operations to
achieve identical sequences now the
state-of-the-art technology at the time
was called a rotor encryption machine we
are all familiar with the mechanical
process of an odometer which takes a
long time to finally repeat its cycle
now imagine we scramble the numbers on
the wheels of the odometer when it ticks
forward a new shift could be generated
by adding up each number on the rotors
this is the rough idea behind rotor
encryption machines for example the
message attack Northwest would be
encrypted as follows notice how a new
ship is used at each position in the
message with three rotors each with 26
numbers the length of the sequence
before repeating is 26 times 26 times 26
this is equivalent to having a list of
shifts 17,576 numbers long
understand that each rotor position is
equivalent to a location in this
sequence the initial machine State is
known as the key setting and the
collection of all possible key settings
defines the key space this key space
increases if the number of ways to
initially configure the machine
increases for example if the rotors can
be rearranged then the order can be
selected in six ways let's visualize the
key space at this point first we choose
from one of six possible rotor orderings
then we select an initial position from
the rotor sequence this gives us a key
space with over a hundred thousand key
settings remember every machine
configuration is a point in this space
when we select a key setting we are
selecting a starting point in this space
which then determines the rest of the
shift sequence give away the key setting
and you give away the entire sequence
the security of rotor machines depends
on both the size of this key space and
the randomness of the key setting during
World War two one of the most important
encryption technologies used by the
German military was known as the Enigma
it was an electromechanical rotor
machine invented by a German engineer at
the end of World War one each rotor
wheel had electrical contacts on either
side with a maze of wirings within so at
each rotor position there was an
electrical path from every input letter
to every output letter when the rotor
advanced an entirely new path was
defined for each letter
during the war they continually tried to
increase the key space of the enigma in
order to make it stronger for example
some changes they made were to add a
fourth rotor wheel and increase the
number of possible rotors you could put
into the machine 260 this had the effect
of massively increasing the key space
near the end of the war the Enigma could
be set up in over 150 million million
million ways guessing the key setting
which was used for a given message was
about as likely as guessing the outcome
of 26 dice rolls this gave the Germans
confidence that the Allies even if they
had a copy of the Enigma could never
check all possible key settings for two
parties to communicate using the Enigma
it required that they first share the
daily key settings this allowed them to
align their machines to the same
position this protocol changed over and
over during the war but generally
involve distributing key sheets in
advance to all operators each day the
operator would cut off the daily
settings and this would tell them the
daily configuration of their machine
such as what rotors to use and the order
of the rotors this key setting was then
to be destroyed after use however one
vital step was left to the operator they
were to select a random initial position
of each rotor before communication began
and a very simple mistake was made by
some fatigued operators we make this
exact same mistake every time we set a
bike lock combination because we tend to
rotate the cylinders only a few clicks
from the initial state or we reuse a
common password this destroyed the
uniform distribution of the initial
rotor position and after it repeated
observations it allowed the Allies to
reverse-engineer the rotor wirings
completely
the second major error was a design
error not a procedural one the enigma
was designed so that an input letter
would never encrypt to itself so given
an encrypted letter such as L you can
now eliminate the possibility that L was
the original letter what they thought
was a strength was actually a weakness
in design and this led to a
code-breaking machine initially designed
by the poles and later improved by the
British American effort the bombe was
multiple enigma rotors chained together
allowing it to rapidly test different
key settings it took advantage of the
fact that common words were known to be
in the original message such as weather
and these came to be known as cribs for
a given message in crib the bomb could
scan through all possible rotor
positions and orders in order to find
possible key settings in a matter of
minutes
this machine allowed the Allies to read
German commands within hours of them
being issued it was a fatal blow to
their combat strategy as the Allies
could anticipate their next move one
fact remains this initial attempt at
automating the one-time pad failed if
the operators had instead ruled dice to
decide their initial rotor positions the
starting point in the sequence could
have been uniformly distributed this
would have prevented the reverse
engineering of the rotor wirings and if
the Enigma allowed letters to be
encrypted to themselves the bomb could
not have taken advantage of cribs and
this would have required the Allies to
check the entire key space which was
impossible even with the fastest
computer repetition reduced the key
space otherwise the outcome of World War
two could have been drastically
different
you